Hi, Neil from BBC Learning English here. Did you know that we are now offering a new,
weekly, extra episode of 6 Minute English exclusively on our website?
So, go to BBCLearningEnglish.com to find your favourite presenters on your favourite
programme. The extra episodes are only available on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com.
See you there.
This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
No one is too small to make a difference. Do you know who said that, Sam?
Wasn't it climate change after this, guess a chin book?
That's right, she went on to say this in her message to world leaders. I don't want you
to be hopeful. I want you to act as if your house is on fire because it is.
Her speech reflected the feelings of many young people around the world who think that
not enough action is being taken on climate change.
And they might be right, judging by the record breaking temperatures that hit Canada and
the northwest of the United States in July this year.
Gressertumberg's plea to act like your house is on fire became a reality for residents
of the small town of Lyson, Canada, which burned to the ground in a shocking world fire,
a fire that is burning strongly in out of control.
So once the litun wildfire yet another climate change wake up call. A wake up call is the
expression used to describe a shocking event that should make people realise that action
is needed to change something.
And they may not, according to some climatologists who worryingly say that what happened in Lyson
should not even have been possible. So in this programme we'll be asking if scientists
have dangerously misunderstood the realities of climate change.
But first it's time for my quiz question and it's about that extreme weather in Canada.
It broke records when the temperature in Litton hit an all time high on the first of July,
so just how hot did it get? Was it A 39.6 degrees, B 49.6 degrees or C 59.6 degrees Celsius?
All those temperatures look really high, especially for snowy Canada. I'll say A 39.6 degrees
C.
Okay Sam, we'll find out at the answer later on. Seeing your hometown burn to the ground
was bad enough, but perhaps even worse was the fact that the wildfires were so unexpected.
According to weather pass in modelling done by a team of Oxford University researchers,
such extreme heat was impossible in theory at least.
The research team was led by a climatologist Gert Jern van Olderberg. Here he is in conversation
with BBC World Service Programme Science in Action.
This is a wake up call beyond the wake up calls that we've had before.
Yes, it's a very big shock in the sense that we thought we knew that how heat waves react
to global warming and within which boundaries they are increasing. Of course they're increasing
in temperature, but it's a gradual process we thought. And then you get this thing and
it's not gradual at all. It's a huge jump.
Professor Van Oldenberg had been studying the impact of global warming on heat waves,
short periods of time when there were there is much hotter than usual.
Along with other climatologists he thought that climate change was gradual, changing or
happening slowly over a long period of time.
But the Canadian heat waves caused him to think again. Instead of being gradual the temperatures
saw a jump or a sudden increase of five degrees. And it's the sudden jump that's got
Professor Van Oldenberg and his team worried.
By collecting data from all over the world climatologists tried to predict changes in
the pattern of global warming.
But as Gert Jern van Oldenberg told BBC World Services Science in Action, the heat wave
inlisten didn't fit these predictions at all.
Everything looked like a nice regular, gradual trend like we were used to up to last year.
And then you suddenly break all your records by four or five degrees. I mean this is something
that's not supposed to happen. And it has really shaken our confidence in how well we understand
the effect of climate change on heat waves.
Despite all his research, Professor Van Oldenberg is still unable to explain such extreme
and sudden changes in the climate. And this he says has shaken his confidence, made
him doubt something that he was certain was true.
And it's this lack of understanding, worrying researchers because as the story of the town
of Litten shows, the effects of climate change may be even worse than expected.
Maybe it's time we all took notice of Gert Jern van Oldenberg's wake up call to take
action on climate change. Especially if even cold northern countries like Canada or Britain
for that matter can experience such extreme changes. Speaking of which Neil, what was the
answer to your quiz question?
Ah yes, in my quiz question I asked you exactly how high the temperature reached in the Canadian
town of Litten. What did you say Sam?
I thought it was a 39.6 degrees Celsius was I right.
Well you were close but in fact it got even hotter actually reaching 49.6 degrees Celsius.
The highest temperature ever recorded in Canada by at least 5 degrees.
Phew, that is hot. Well we'd better recap the vocabulary from this programme because we
might be hearing these words a lot more in the future.
Let's start with a wildfire which is an out of control fire that is burning the countryside.
A wake up call is an event which should make people realise that action needs to be taken
to change a situation.
A heat wave is a period of days or weeks when the weather is much hotter than usual.
A jump is a sudden increase.
Whereas gradual means happening slowly over a long time.
And finally if something shakes your confidence it makes you doubt something that you thought
was true.
That's it for our look at one of the hottest years on record.
Bye for now.
Bye.